buscando entre los escombros los equipos
de rescate intentan desesperadamente
encontrar supervivientes
después de que los ataques de misiles
rusos durante la noche del viernes en la
pequeña ciudad costera de cervic a
destruyeran estos apartamentos en
campamentos cercanos se anegaron acton a
que tiene todos los que estaban dentro
de en ese momento probablemente estén
todos muertos la vecina era una persona
muy buena es tan horrible
simplemente murió en mis brazos
el armario se cayó el frigorífico se me
cayó encima apenas puedes sacar a los
niños el espacio era muy pequeño los
empuje pero no puede pasarte hasta que
llegó la ayuda en estas excursiones los
ataques se produjeron a unos 50
kilómetros de la ciudad portuaria de
odessa y comenzaron justo un día después
de que moscú retirará sus fuerzas del
puesto de avanzada del mar negro en la
isla de las serpientes lo que las
autoridades ucranianas interpretan como
una venganza todo ello a pesar de que
rusia presentó su salidad con un gesto
de buena voluntad para ayudar a
desbloquear las exportaciones de grano
el líder de ucrania expresó su
indignación por los ataques
calificándolos de actos de terror ruso
estos misiles cache 22 estaban diseñados
para destruir portaaviones y otros
grandes buques de guerra carmen
y el ejército ruso los utilizó contra un
edificio normal de 9 plantas con gente
civil normal de viaje pobre joven botín
a moscú han llegado hasta ahora su
responsabilidad y el portavoz del
kremlin ha repetido que no apunta a
zonas residenciales sin embargo estos
ataques se producen apenas unos días
después de que misiles rusos atacaran un
concurrido centro comercial en el centro
de ucrania matando al menos a 19
personas